what's up guys its tracks and today
we're gonna be breaking down some
celebrity chains independence quavo
alright this is a whole jewelry set for
quavo right here the first piece that
attracted me is this quavo piece that's
actually ended of itself wearing other
pieces the setting could be a notch
higher but it's a tough setting to do
especially in the dreads you got the
rose gold in the eyeglasses there's not
a lot of room to hold the prongs
together so the setter has to be very
very careful because you could damage it
and then diamonds are gonna fall out
perpetually they're all hanging on four
prong diamond tennis chains tennis chain
is a four prong chain that has matching
size diamonds going all the way around
it's flexible but it doesn't swing like
a regular chain so the diamonds always
face forward so that's a very desirable
chain a lot of people look for those
chains but they can't could never really
afford them but these guys got six or
seven at a time a lot of rappers trying
to look like that gucci mane so he's got
his 10:17 glacier gang pendant it's on a
Miami Cuban choker three rows now the
setting looks like it was done in a rush
because some of these guys they always
wanted pieces in a rush and then the
setters just hammer in a way that's the
only critique on it but that's heavy
materials you can see it's a heavy piece
especially the Cuban choker it's really
really nice I know this pen is made in
the south because I know that designs I
know their setters especially with this
with this bail it's it's a bail that's
coming from down there it's very popular
in the south if we don't really make
that in New York the bail is what the
chain goes through so you got this Miami
Cuban choker going through the bail it's
a heavy bail the the beautiful thing
about this piece is that the bail and
the chain fit perfectly and I think they
were done at the same time specifically
for each other that's why they fit so
good
it's a classic hip-hop piece it's a
classic case to rock out
you got a really intricate piece here
this is something that he was doing
obviously in his later stage where he
was getting something
custom-made from his ideas from his
designs the quality is very high could
ready tell just by the picture you got
graduated diamonds coming out as
leopards mouths that are interconnected
graduated diamonds are diamonds starting
from small to large we got the smaller
stones roughly about seven pointers and
they're going all the way up to fifteen
or twenty pointers right down there in
the center so then so that gives it an
interesting look that's taking jewelry
to another level so the more pointers
the larger the diamond the more
expensive the diamond when you're doing
at something that's intricate and
interesting it's not all about the most
expensive that's too crude you want to
work on an artistic sense this piece
definitely achieves that it could go
even farther the only thing I would say
it might be missing is a little bit of
color or a little bit of texture on this
band that's going around but other than
that it's an immaculate piece off set so
here you got a multi-tier collection of
offset jewelry my most favorite piece
out here is that Miami Cuban and rose
gold so you got a Cuban Lincoln you got
a Miami Cuban like a lot of people call
different links by different names
it's a curb link or a Cuban link it has
more spaces in between the links this is
a tighter link it's very very strong
it's almost an industrial-strength link
it's very heavy it's beautiful and gold
that's really an almost an investment
piece
you got another little mini Miami that's
iced out under that's also very nice
that's holding up that freakazoids East
which is another classic that turned a
lot of heads that top one that top
chokers got big diamonds in it they look
like at least 70 pointers he bought them
I'm sure at the right price but those
particular diamonds have a little hint
of yellow on them but most interesting
piece however is this cross that's on
there it's got a princess cut pink in
the center and princess cuts on each
corner they care and then this is two
and a half carat with the pink stone so
I paid 220 just for this piece right
here then after this piece I got the
offset so I got the letters actually
dripping there's a certain difficulty
level on creating a drip piece because
it has to do with the artist that's
making the model on the computer
3d printing pendants started probably in
the late 90s and use very rare to find a
good
3d model maker now you can find people
that are going to sculpt your face you
know better than it is in real life when
you're 3d printing your printing in wax
and you can have it with the diamond
holes ready or you can have a hand
setting afterwards where usually you're
printing in wax and then you mold it and
cast it into gold
so here offset is wearing a whole
collection whole slew of jewelry got
layered a bunch of 10s change those are
very expensive now the quality control
is just a big chunk with a lot of
diamonds very nice setting on that but
very simple very straightforward piece
the only piece that I haven't seen
before is this big drip piece it's a
brand drop drop top it looks nice it's a
it's a nice setting that it goes all the
way around it's a lot of materials a lot
of diamonds in that piece the way he
layered his pieces is classic migos
they're the best at their jewelry game
they started a trend for a lot of
jewelry I mean it's very hard to tell
who really really started it Gucci Mane
had it they were kind of following
behind Gucci's footsteps but they put
their own spin on it and but they took
the jewelry to another level two chains
you got to change wearing a large
variety of different types of pieces
that a manufacturer looks like by
different jewelers you have this NS
piece at the top that's white and rose
gold different layering different signs
Diamond that's a very nice piece it was
done very nice it's a straightforward 3d
model but the setting on it looks good
then you have something that looked a
little bit older it's that true piece at
the bottom hanging on a tennis chain
it's a nice tennis chain it's yellow
gold completely different color of gold
completely different model maker on that
what I like the most so far is these
interesting diamond change that he's
wearing at the top those are completely
different and together it looks like a
wild party on his neck and they're going
down at different layers the one that's
hanging the lowest is the Pharaoh piece
with the Cuban rim on a Cuban chain the
chains are connected directly to the
piece I just one of the piece was the
star think of something like you think
you would see all knives or something
like that more likely the King piece and
then you
have some really sick chocolates with
baguettes that's probably his most
recent pieces added to his collection
the baguettes are a different shape of
diamonds they weren't always popular
it's a very simple shape it doesn't have
that many facets it's not gonna give you
that type of shine that you're looking
forward if you want more pop you're
gonna go with round diamonds but if
you're bored of that and you want to do
something new then you go with these
baguettes vic mensa so here you have
think mentor wearing something
completely different from all the trends
this is really artistic pieces of
jewelry it looks like 18 karat gold it
might be a designer piece it doesn't
look like it was custom-made
maybe the mask was added on to it later
maybe not it's not the fully ice look
it's not that but if you're more into
art and you're more artistic this is the
look you're trying to go for so these
are little pumps signature pieces it's
got a specific type of Cuban link that
was modified just for him it's flooded
with massive amounts of character
diamonds very high-quality mr. Miami
Gucci link has both Miami Cubans and the
Gucci link so this is the first one ever
made
got two safety locks will never pop on
him then he's got the little pump
underneath that with the baguette teeth
rose gold hair different colors of gold
is a heavy hitter pieces very expensive
he might have spent them at least
300,000 on it nobody wants to spend that
much money on a piece unless they're a
young dude with money to burn future
all right futures pulling out all the
stops on this chain set he's got one on
top of the other atenist until Miami
Cuban alright we're doing two Toads
that's more intricate that means that
links have to be assembled completely
differently and it's made to order but
the one that takes the cake is the one
that's shining on top it's a graduated
tennis chain this particular one that
looks like the larger ones are one
characters those are expensive diamonds
and they look very very clear that chain
itself is gonna be over a hundred
thousand the the chokers and the Cubans
are fifty thousand a piece so he's got a
lot on his neck right there it's a
little bit more grown-up it's not the
little pump with the lead
pouring out that colors and all this
other stuff very nice though Wiz Khalifa
so Wiz here has got some really
interesting pieces he's using gemstones
he's being more creative than the
average rapper if you got a couple of
gold ropes and a little tennis chain at
the camp piece that's a fully ice piece
very straightforward very simple you've
got this interesting center stone on
this hard pendant that's going around
that particular piece might be a citrine
in the center or an amber place
interestingly with the rest of his
jewelry
Trippi red so trippy red he's got a
really unique jewelry style here first
and foremost he's got this monster
diamond chains it's fully iced it's
custom made just for him he's got a
Gucci link mixed in there that's a very
expensive chain he spent a lot of money
on that he's got a classic also Jesus
head on there that looks like it's got
black diamonds it's a dope piece with
the white diamond crown that's something
more traditional more standard you got
the ball and chain piece on as well
black diamonds with the white diamond
spikes cartoon characters multicolored
very cartoony young personally I think
that little Pumped takes the cake when
it comes to these younger dudes he's got
beautiful pieces and they're done really
really nice but these are really dope
and right up there it's a matter of
opinion Meek Mill
Meek Mill is a heavy hitter jewelry
trend setter the team chasers piece
everybody copied that layering they had
different logos different sayings and um
I've seen them all I've made a couple
myself of course you've got the
signature Cuban and every rapper every
heavy hitter has to have fully ice that
once done well as well he's got a bunch
of tennis chains that's where the money
is that's what the big boys have and
then of course you've got the picture
frame pendants he made that a trend as
well lost loved ones family members
there some people are doing their
animals that they've lost very big trend
setter so people are looking up to Meek
Mill timeout of the Creator here Tyler
the Creator is wearing something that is
very very unique and very very
interesting it looks like a designer
piece looks like something that Louie
would make or Gucci would make or some
very high-end designer this was
something that was manufactured that
took a lot of time no corners were cut
on this piece everything was thought
about everything was proportionate
everything was done correct and this is
something you might see in a museum one
day when he's done with it
a little woozy burn little Aussie vert
classic wrap jewelry pieces this is
probably earlier in his career because
he's just got a little Cuban chain on
with one row of diamonds maybe 20,000
25,000 doesn't compare to what he
probably has today he's got his heart
with his number to fully iced Hero
sievert is wearing his boozy okay that's
a pretty good 3d model it has all of the
little features of the Uzi and things
like that you've got a really
interesting puffy Gucci link with
diamonds on the side that's a very
interesting chain and what's hanging on
it is this Megalodon tooth on that tooth
the diamond quality is very high I could
tell by the way they react with the
light from the camera so that piece
takes the cake out of all of them here
you have a one of the most difficult
pieces of jewelry to manufacture which
is a custom link it's difficult to do
because the links have to interact with
one another organically you got to have
$100,000 to get started that's the whole
point of jewelry everybody wants a piece
like that not everybody could get it and
that's why jewelry is
[Music]